but just briefly my work is really about
light it's all about understanding the
phenomenology of light primarily
daylight but also artificial light and I
became involved in working with light as
a medium basically in the late 1960s
when is it school and that basically led
me into glass as a material to capture
and manifest and sort of explore
qualities of light and information
basically that the content of light in
the work that I did so a lot of the work
I under start to show you a few projects
which in the late 60s and 70s we're
really film projects that explored a
phenomenon of light and how you might
capture a phenomenon that you would see
in nature synthesize it and establish it
as something you would experience in an
urban environment how you sort of
connect people as Richard were saying
how you connect people to a very
richness of urban life where nature
exists around us but we tend to not
observe it or see it so my work really
goes very much in the direction of
having people understand the richness of
an urban context and what architecture
can do to explore that amplify it and
sort of sustained a different sense of
our lives with an urban environment and
as Martha was saying I've also can sort
of parallel with this work that I do as
an architect and previously sort of an
artist I do a lot of work for Corning
Glass Works which is a very large
technical glass company which you may be
aware of and I started working for them
in the 1970s on a lot of photosensitive
glasses glasses that respond to
different wavelengths of light and I've
continued to work with them today and
we're currently working on a lot of
glasses which I'll talk about later but
all of these classes today which are
used for all of our cellphones and
computers extremely thin glasses
literally thinner glasses now that are
much thinner than this piece of paper
and are hundreds of times stronger than
the glass were familiar with
and they're currently glasses that you
can roll up roll up the glass comes at a
big role almost like fabric so one of
the big things we're working on today
our means of transforming construction
utilizing thin film glasses which deals
with weight and you know quantity of
glass necessary to enclose buildings and
the structure of thin-film structures in
all these different aspects of glass
that you couldn't necessarily explore in
conventional types of classes but I'll
talk about that a little bit but I would
introduce you to my own work and how it
has basically I guess sort of morphed
over the years from work done in the
early 1970s I'm just going to touch on
one or two of these to give you a sense
of where I come from conceptually in
work but I basically studied chemistry
and had a great interest in biology and
chemistry together so a lot of the
film's deal with events you see in
nature and this happened to be a small
River in Puget Sound you know this is
done 35 years ago almost 40 years ago a
small river in Puget Sound where a
friend of mine was doing his PhD work
and they manage different genetic
strains of salmon that release them into
the river and then he obviously come
back and the idea here was that over the
river you'd build scaffolding over the
river and then a series of cameras that
would look down into the surface of the
river and then you would take that
series of films and then you would
project them basically in a museum or in
a gallery so you walk into the museum
basically on the floor our fragments of
that river with the fish is you sir see
here Sam and moves through one film
frame through darkness at the next film
friend external brain so you have a
sequential capture of migration
basically the notion of migration sort
of moving through the museum and what
interests me I guess about these these
phenomenon and when you observe them is
that the content of things we look at is
much broader than we
we tend to our eye tends to narrow down
to very familiar things and this
basically sort of discounts a lot of
information is around us so I'm very
interested in how we recapture the
wealth of content that exists in the
world around us and bring your attention
to those specific things so this is just
a little way of sort of demonstrating
what this project was was about the sort
of the river the movement of the fish
over the river but by shooting the film
and then you change the timing of the
film slightly instead of running the
film at the conventional speed you print
the images so they repeat each other and
they hold themselves a little bit longer
while you begin to realize that the
image isn't necessarily just looking
through the surface of the water and
seeing the fish but if you change the
timing that same film image all of a
sudden reveals the fact that you're
looking at an absolutely perfect image
of the sky reflected in the surface so
it's really taking the surface of water
and the information that's seen through
the water the information that exists on
the surface of the water and the
information is reflected off the surface
of the water so oftentimes use this idea
of water as a corollary to glass that
glass is a material that has content
reflected on its surface content within
it and content through it so the
material has a capacity to inform us in
a much richer way than we tend to
acknowledge and this is a project done
about ten years later for a family in
California that had a very extensive art
collection and there's a small River on
their property and they had a bridge
that would lead you over the small River
and an a commissioned me to do this
bridge for them and the idea here is
that you cross out onto this glass
platform then you move along this glass
platform to the other shore of the river
so that moment in time when you're
crossing the river isn't necessarily
just going from side to side but extends
your experience of that particular
ecology or invite
so this glass platform is really
suspended over the surface of the river
the idea is that the light comes down
hits the river reflects back up so the
glass platform which is translucent
carries with it the image of the the
water itself so the the idea here is how
and this is really sort of to show you
one or two of these projects it's sort
of how I tried to move from doing work
in the art world primarily which is a
very limited audience to how you move
out of that into the architectural world
which is where I originally studied how
do you build things permanently that can
capture in a conceptual way sort of a
richness of our environment so the
notion here is that you walk on this
glass platform you've basically
extracted the surface of the water and
made that the surface that you're
walking on and by just using slightly
reflective panels of glass they say
basically superimpose reflected images
of the landscape around you so the
bridge actually sort of consolidates the
landscape on the one hand and that also
sort of lifts this quality the water
below it so it's a way of how do you
create environments where all of a
sudden you begin understand these
elements there around you in a very
different way you sort of build a new
new experience or new environment so
other projects done about that same time
and this is perhaps a little more
conventional is a small project done for
a client out in the Midwest and this is
a the only the only desire on the
clients part that he would be built at
this is a chapel it's sort of a small
chapel that's part of a seminary and the
only desire we had was to maintain
totally clear views of the nature
outside so you'd sit in the building
look out at this very beautiful
landscape and the trees you would have
been happy with that but I wanted to try
to figure out a way to do more than just
have a clear glass window but how you
would sort of animate the space so
you're looking through the window and
the window is about 12 meters tall it's
quite a tall window there's single
single pieces of glass and run the full
height and then there are these panels
of glass which are roughly that
dimension that's stiffen these vertical
pieces so you look at it nature beyond
and there's sort of this overlay of
another layer of glass in front of it
and basically what happens is sunlight
comes in portion of the light is
reflected portion of the light is
transmitted and you end up with this
idea that the light basically occupies
the space it comes in and sort of
dominates and takes over the space and
what's happening here is that as you
have clouds in the sky basically that
image is brought in and projected on the
wall so you actually see clouds moving
our birds and then when the trees have
like summer and fall when you see those
leaves moving that image is projected
down in so in a way it's connected to
film it's a bit cinematic in that sense
that's bringing abstracted qualities of
nature into the space and you observe
them in a very different way than you
would otherwise and of course the
dynamic of daylight is you walk in here
sometimes it might not be anything on
the wall or there might be just very
subtle pieces of this for all of a
sudden hold image appears or disappears
so this is great sort of dynamic and I
think that that's fundamentally what
interests me there's a quality of
animation that we lose but we need to
somehow reintroduce and then secondarily
is this this concept which is something
you'll see in most all the work we do is
that the window is no longer a single
piece of glass but you've taken that
idea of boundary boundary condition
between exterior environment and
interior environment you've expanded
that boundary so you have an
interstitial zone that reinterprets the
relationship between exterior
environment and interior vitamins no
longer glass as a transparent material
that's abstract basically glass
historically and the modernist movement
has been an abstraction there's no
material you are seamless with the outer
the outer environment Irv I ramires
seamlessly joined and the glass as a
material has no physical presence so
Mauer work is really just the opposites
about how does the glass device or
structure or material clearly define the
differentiation between interior and
exterior there is a richness of
differentiation it's not the same it's
not the same interior as it is outside
so you have a way of doing that so some
of these projects are very simple again
this is a not dissimilar to that Chapel
project this is here on Columbus Avenue
it's downtown near Lincoln Center it was
just a wall on a building a brick
building and the neighborhood or the
community group was very upset about
this new building that was built and
then we were ultimately sort of
commissioned to come up with something
that would change that quality that
people would experience in a fairly
dense urban area more residential area
instead of this large blank brick wall
so what you're looking at is a glass
surface it's actually a glass that's
used on solar collectors and then these
are glass fins that extend off the
surface perpendicularly so you have a
background glass and the glass fin that
extends off the surface and it's very
static as a structure of course but if
you look at it at any time of the day or
any time of the year it's completely
different like this is the same moment
in time this is looking at it from one
direction and that's looking at it from
another direction so it's the idea
building a what we would refer to as a
responsive surface it's a surface that
responds to you meaning your place your
your position within that immediate
urban context and the position of the
Sun so it's always it's always that
dynamic between where's the source of
light and where are you in relationship
so it's something different every time
you look at it and it also is designed
to this is critical in a city it's
obviously blocked many hours of the day
there's no light available to it in
terms of direct light so this is
actually in an afternoon where the light
is actually the Sun is beyond it it's
technically in shadow but it picks up on
different qualities of light and then it
projects light
down into the street so often times it
will animate the street so you get these
effects which are say light coming off
of a building that might be four or five
blocks away it's just a random piece of
light that hits the surface we see this
all the time in the city but it's
normally it hits a brick wall tore his
cement and it's not anything remarkable
but as soon as it hits a surface like
this all of a sudden create something
very dynamic and the idea of the wall
here is I guess best exhibited there
which was this idea of the flat wall not
having any sort of dimension to it and
sort of suggesting that it's a it's
actually just this sheer surface but as
you can see what happens it looks like
the fin the idea of the fin was that the
fin would go to the glass service then
it appears if it's extending back into
some other space behind it so the the
wall tends to set up this idea that
there's occupied space or other space
dimensional space behind it so these are
just you know just a few collections
small projects that demonstrate
different ways working with light and
then this is something down Washington
DC I've done about 10 years ago but it's
a very good example of something that
we're trying to get a better
understanding of and execute projects
more in a more informed way this is a
building built for a large sort of law
firm and the architects had designed a
atrium space which had a skylight that's
about 20 meters long and about 3 meters
wide and the space itself is about 50
meters tall so very narrow slot very
deep space in the building with offices
looking into it obviously those
dimensions effectively mean you're going
to get light from 1130-2 1230 like in
the noon time to get a little bit of
light coming and that's it so this is a
device or structure that we built which
made out of glass as a center piece of
glass that's relatively narrow at the
bottom and then it goes up to about
three meters in diameter at the top so
it's a glass
inside of a fabric structure and what
we're doing here is on the roof is a
heliostat obviously a tracking mirror
it's not so large you know it's maybe
you know the mirrors may be this big you
know not much bigger than a maybe half
of that window over there the Sun it
tracks the Sun sunlight it then hits a
secondary mirror and then the secondary
mirror drops the light down inside the
cylinder so what's happening is the
glass it's a special glass that has a
particular prismatic surface on it so
we're dropping the light down into the
cylinder over roughly 40 meters and the
glass the light is falling at about two
degree angles it comes down so light
hits the glass and it's refracted out so
you're taking the light and you're
constantly over that full dimension
you're bending the light and projecting
it out and you see the light on the
glass itself you see the light on the
fabric that's around it and then you see
the light that's passed through it and
you see it again on the wall and the
principal here and this is just
something that I think we all need to
learn more about is that if you think of
that it's just one small window it's
basically just maybe two-thirds the size
of that one window that's all the light
we have but you're actually then using
it to illuminate a huge space and it's
only an example of saying that we don't
know how to use the light there's so
much intensity in sunlight your eye
tends to close and it creates very high
contrast and all that so then we're not
really using that sunlight very well but
if you have a way of distributing it and
having the light fall on multiple
surfaces you all of a sudden the
perception is there's an enormous amount
of light so it's just a principle that
we think is something we need to work
more aggressively on buildings and this
of course is at the very bottom of the
space and we were obviously not able to
use all the light anyway so that you're
still getting you know very high amounts
of light at the bottom that you haven't
you haven't quite used so there's an
example about how daylight works and
then this is a I'm sure showing you a
range of things just maybe get you to
think about light and a different way
than you typically do this is a project
for the olympics in sydney australia and
the olympics were all about reclaiming
industrial landscapes like an old oil
refinery and steel yard right outside of
Sydney on the harbour and they wanted to
reclaim that for the Olympic Park and
turn it into a public park afterwards so
the whole project was about reclaiming
toxic land reclaiming water sources that
had been contaminated all these things
and they wanted people to realize that
what had been gone what they've gone
through to reclaim this whole space so
we we wanted to try to use this idea of
water and water vapor in the sense that
we know that the water is evaporating at
the surface from bodies of water or even
from the ground that water's then going
up into the air microscopically
condenses into clouds and then obviously
sort of comes back down but creating a
synthetic cloud what we did here is this
goes down into a tidal stream here's the
main bridge you entered the Olympic Park
on this bridge you go over this tidal
stream we're taking the water from the
stream and filtering and pumping it up
these mass which you can see i'll just
show you the mass come across they
create a threshold that everybody walks
through so you've creating this cloud
that sort of floats across here and then
there's another device in the distance
there which I'll explain to you in a
moment which is also a heliostat and
this is what we're trying to do we're
trying to create essentially like a
mirage like how do you in the middle of
the day under a bright blue sky direct
Sun how do you create forms
space so people sort of see it so these
were tests that we were doing this is a
little misting system industrial misting
system mirror sunlight hitting the
mirror and bouncing it back how you get
these these broad beams of light just in
the middle of the day appears in the sky
and it has a lot to do with filtration I
mean if this is a regular mirror you
wouldn't see this because its all full
spectrum light if you bounce back full
spectrum light your eye doesn't see it
but if you filter the light we're
letting all the blue light go through
and we're only bouncing back yellow
light so your eyes very sensitive to
yellow and all of a sudden you see it
and we're taking that whole thing into
effect here's the you know the men sort
of installing couple these mass the top
part of the mass the top 5 meters is for
the misting system and then this is the
mirror which is about a half a kilometer
away up on its own mast and what happens
is this basically the mass create this
synthetic cloud overhead Sun comes down
hits the mirror a lot of the lights
going through the mirror but the yellow
light is sort of being bounced back so
all of a sudden overhead you get these
ribbons of light that sort of appear
overhead and it's obviously the first
principle is simply that the light is
always around us the light is always
there only when it hits the surface to
you acknowledge it right so it's there
so that's all about the presence of
light and the surface upon which it
falls that makes it a way it makes you
aware of it so this is really all about
weather conditions like occasionally
there makes this sort of form sometimes
they're like localized sometimes this
beam of light will be two kilometers
long it's like a solid bar of life it
goes for about two kilometers and just
sort of see it in sky overhead so it's
it's the same principle obviously that's
happening back here and the clouds
beyond it Suns coming down it's
illuminating the top of the cloud the
cloud so dense that the light can't get
through and therefore it appears to be
dark underneath so we're basically just
taking that instead of sunlight coming
down we're sort of bringing it
projecting it horizontally
and that's at sunset it looks looks
quite different at sunset and then so
anyway those are arranged things we do a
lot of those types of projects because
they're great and fun and sort of fun to
explore them and do the development on
them and they let you look at different
phenomenon in a more experimental way
and then we do a lot of work on
buildings all over the world this is the
Hearst headquarters here in New York
which is down here on Ethan ooh the
original building was built 1928 new
building was done with Foster and we do
a lot of work with Foster I worked on
his very first building a Hong Kong
Shanghai Bank a million years ago but we
were asked to take that this is the
historic building facade here it's a
section through the building you're
looking at the Stork facade on eighth
Avenue and then the beginning of the new
tower behind it is how how you bring
people into that original entry up to
the new Lobby so we worked on
establishing these large skylights in
the space and then primarily design this
element here which is made out of glass
it's a glass wall it's three stories
high and the escalators come up through
it but it's linked to sort of the
management the cooling systems of the
building we take the rain water off the
roof we bring it down it's stored below
this surface and it's chilled the
chilled water is sort of brought up and
then run over the surface so chilled
water is very cold waters run over that
surface and it creates a whole
convection current in the space and the
humidity basically condenses on that
cold water surface so you're using water
as a dehumidification system and cooling
system in the lobby so on one hand it's
a cooling system secondarily you're
taking all this daylight and much like a
periscope you're taking this bright
light bringing it down and bouncing it
out to the street so when you're on the
street you look into the building
instead of seeing a dark volume or dark
lobby it's a very bright surface and it
brings you in so the way we just work
with cast glass here these are machine
graphite molds and pouring the glass
these big casting
they're like there may be that long and
that's thick they're basically prisms
and then those prisms are laid up into
this wall system and below this is so
chilled water system underneath there
and then when you walk in this way to
Caesar walk in it's acting as a
periscope so by looking at that surface
you're actually looking at the light
that's directly overhead and then the
water is running over that cooling the
space but the water also serves the
purpose of the population of this
building is about 3,500 people you know
so there's that many people coming and
going a very large dining area upon the
supper floor suits at times you have big
high populations of people than very few
people so the water flow is actually
choreographed the number of people so
you'd be greater cooling when there's
greater numbers of people you need the
white noise to sort of cancel out the
sound in a space at that same time so
it's always considered this whole
flowing surface next you as you go up
and down so this is something that we do
a lot of and and and really try to seek
out projects to do these types of things
where it's combining sort of them the
maintenance issues of the building by
how do you cool the building how do you
change qualities of acoustics in the
building how do you do the light
qualities and building how does
something which in one hand just as very
beautiful object or sculpture in itself
but how do you overlay on that something
that's a little richer and more you know
it's more of a giving opportunity within
the building and that's not dissimilar
to this project which I hope you may get
down to see this today but this is a
seven World Trade Center tower this is
the first building build down the World
Trade Center site we began working on
this in October actually just a
afterwards that would collapse but to
build two big buildings here familiar
with her behind it they came down you
probably read about this building when
those big buildings came down around it
the original building here had a lot of
diesel fuel storage in the building it
had the New York City emergency response
headquarters was in the building and the
FBI and the CIA all of those agencies
were in the building and they had an
enormous amount of fuel storage because
they had offline generators so they
could just operate regardless of what
else was happening but the lower this is
particularly of interest perhaps to you
the lower sixth floors of the building
originally was a power substation so the
power coming into the city came into the
substation and then above the substation
had these big transfer trusses so the
building's collapse Billy came down
everybody got out of the built building
safely but at the diesel fuel in that
original building caught on fire
eventually softened the trusses and then
they building collapsed on itself so it
was a much bigger building than the the
two towers and in terms of square
footage but the reason this building was
built so quickly is that they had to get
this power substation up and operational
as quickly as possible because all the
power for the road Trade Center site and
much of the power for downtown Manhattan
came through this building so this is
the this is the you know this is many
years later this is like 2004 after all
the excavation work and the new
foundations coming up this is basically
the power substation so the lower eight
floors of the building is basically
solid concrete box and it has five big
transformers on the north side and five
on the south side and the lobby is
basically shoehorned between the
substation and these are big
transformers these are you know almost
30 meet at 30 meters tall you know these
are like they come in by boat they come
in by barge and they're put in here and
so we were involved we have hired by the
develop the owner very early the
architects was Skidmore
that we were charged with the
development of whole exterior of the
building so the first order of business
was like you have a concrete power
substation in that center of downtown
Manhattan that whole part of the city's
going to change its going to be more of
a cultural center it's going to be a
more active pedestrian environment that
it used to be so this building had to be
something better than what you would
conventionally think our con Edison
friends would provide so we were hired
both by the building developer and by
the power company to develop the whole
exterior of the building so this part of
the building which is where the
transformers are had to be fifty percent
open for natural ventilation and then we
needed to come up with a concept that
would allow us to develop an idea so the
whole notion of the entire tower is
about light so there's two surfaces
there's an exterior surface of the tower
and then just set back from that
external surface is another surface
which is about eight inches back so both
of those surfaces are meant to capture
qualities of light that are unique to
Manhattan or New York qualities of light
downtown Manhattan and the idea here is
these are a company that we began to
work with two that may actually make
mining equipment they've never done
architectural project before and water
filtration systems but we began
developed this system where there's a
outer surface of these heavier stainless
steel ribs prisms and then there's an
inner surface of these these prisms and
those panels would then be put up onto
the building and in the daytime the
daylight wing would interact with this
outer surface and you would get effects
like that and then at nighttime it would
interact with the inner surface so in
the daytime you tend to see these other
surfaces this is the base of the
building coming up and some of the
earlier earlier panels going on the
building but you end up with this I mean
you end up with a skin that works on the
principle of your eye typically when
your eye looks at something
it looks at the brightest surface and
then your eye tends to let's stop at
that surface it doesn't really challenge
you to see beyond that surface so the
daytime you sort of see the surface and
by rotating the prisms slightly on the
surface it's basically just reflecting
two slightly different views there's
nothing this is just about reflected
light and then diffusing it slightly so
it's not a mirror it's just slightly
less than the mirror so you get this
sort of quality of light in the daytime
and then at nighttime we're illuminating
the inner surface of the screen so
inside behind that outer surface are LED
lights that illuminate that inner screen
so you see the nighttime view there so
the principle is simply the wall is 50%
opens if you walk up to this you look
right through it but by lighting the
outer surface with daylight you think
that's the surface of the building
letting the inner surface you think
that's the building and you never your I
never looks back to see the Transformers
behind it so here you have a view of
that on the outside and it's linked up
to a series of cameras that are
activated by people so the light
actually sort of tracks the movement of
people on the building and that's the
base of the building so it's all about
working with daylight on the exterior of
the building it obviously has to deal
with issues of blast I mean the
Transformers exploding protecting the
pedestrian so it doesn't come out of the
street so it has all those overlays to
it and then the main entry of the
building this is the first building to
go up in downtown Manhattan and it's
actually what it is like the first leads
silver building in the city but being
the first building after nine eleven
there was an enormous amount of concern
as you might imagine about well people
can occupy big buildings again or not or
what do you do with a big building the
same location is it gonna be a sense of
whatever fear about being in the
building and then dirt is everybody
going to want the buildings would be
more closed and sense of security
through use of more concrete or
something but the principle that we were
working with here is how you provide the
highest level of secure
but nobody actually knows it so you keep
the building's they appear to be as open
as possible and as Dale it as possible
and as welcoming as possible but this
whole wall system that's here and the
entries is all designed for very very
high blacks like truckload glass and you
can see these are cable systems the
whole system is built on cables that
allow for the force of a instantaneous
explosion that that sort of wave of
force that comes off at the cable is
allowed or allowed to move the glass
panels actually slip and then on the
return they come back into position so
the whole wall is built around
absorption of energy rather than pure
resistance of energy and then you go
into the building and then there's a
second wall there's another wall that
you'll see inside the building which was
a collaboration with an artist named
Jenny Holzer which has these tax led
texts on a surface and this again is
actually another blast wall that
protects the elevator core of the
building so this is again like where we
get involved in something where it's
obviously an aesthetic goal but it's
overlaid with many other levels of
concern whether its energy issues or
security issues but you don't want
people to recognize that as an overt
sort of effort it's just sort of put
into the system so that's the lobby part
of the building how that you'll see and
then that's the overall building but the
other principle or point I just wanted
to make in this innocent in this brief
talk is that in working with light and
when you're building buildings in the
city large scale buildings you're
obviously occupying a slice of a public
resource I mean if you think of daylight
as a public resource buildings are
constantly occupying that public
resource so how does the building sort
of provide some return for that
occupancy and normally we always think
about buildings for the occupant like
you've privatized the public resource
you have daylight we all deal with
daylight for the occupied space
improving that work environment of
course that's what we're trying to do
with
make that a better environment for work
but simultaneously there needs to be a
reciprocal responsibility to provide
light to the public and serve engaged
public with a richer sense of light on
the exterior of the building so the
principle on this building was very
large lights of clear glass that run
floor to ceiling and in fact they go
beyond the floor this little detail that
we developed where you're looking at a
section of the building this is what's
referred to as the spandrel section of
the building this is the structure of
the building where you have all your
steel and some of your sprinklers all of
that this would be the ceiling of one
office floor the glass comes right to
the ceiling and starts down that glass
comes down it goes right past the floor
slab it's sealed at the back of the
floor slab comes down and overhangs the
spandrel and then we've curved this
spandrel panel at the back slightly so
it's actually like a slight lens and
then at the base what we've done is
introduced a reflector so conventionally
when you're looking up in a building
like this is looking at the spandrel
section it's like a slightly corrugated
surface as you might imagine on the
corrugation the sunlight the sunlights
obviously hitting the top but what
you're looking at from the street is
actually the shadowed part of it and
this is like one of the phenomena if you
look in New York Times building it's one
of the phenomena why it appears darker
it's actually you're looking at the
surface that's getting back to you the
light from the ground rather than the
light from the Sun but the taking this
idea of what's in the shadow of the
corrugation we actually introduce a
reflector at the sill the light comes
down and it bounces back up so we've
actually put blue light back up into the
shadow and the rationale for that is
that the blue light basically fills this
whole day lighting reflector and this is
something you don't see on the building
because it's out it's outside and not
visible from below but there is this
blue reflector that runs around every
floor and the principle is that a blue
light when you look at the building
basically merges with the blue of the
sky around it so what is the structure
is given the same lighting level and
quality of light with the sky
so it disappears often times then the
glass panels just look like they're
floating down to get these cassettes of
glass that come down then other times
depending on where you are all of those
daylighting reflectors just light up so
you have in the upper part of the
building you have the outer glass layer
which is giving you some of this
reflective quality here and then you
have this curved reflector which is sort
of the sky-plane behind it so you have
that same dimension and as you come down
to the base of the building as I showed
you a moment ago that stainless steel
prisms on the outside work with daytime
daylight and in their screen we're
sleeping with our official light so the
whole building has a dimension to it
that's all about light striking multiple
surfaces and therefore the building
becomes much richer it's no longer just
a model of monolithic surface and it
takes on a more positive sort of quality
of light in the neighborhood and then
I'll just conclude quickly with this
last project which is thinking about
light in a very different way where
you're working say in the Middle East
where you have enormous amount of light
of course and then how you bring those
late levels down to a reasonable level
both for the thermal performance of the
building certainly but also just for
your sensibility of your eyes sort of
adapting to it so this is the
reorganization sorry designed with a new
Israel Museum it's in Jerusalem and we
worked better throughout the last six
years and was just opened last year but
the original buildings were built 1964
they're sort of concrete boxes that were
done in 1964 with very small windows at
the top of them and we wanted to design
buildings these are the new buildings
which are totally made out of glass all
glass not even insulated glass just
laminated clear glass which sort of
meant that you had to modify what light
gets in the building or prevent any
light from getting the building so this
is the original campus and we took out
some roads and reorganized buildings and
tore down some buildings and basics or
be organized the whole space over about
acres and originally you'd have to walk
in go all the way up this hill over into
that building then down and you arrived
the museum entry and obviously there was
no handicapped accessibility so one of
our major things was how to reintroduce
a connection to nature it's very
beautiful landscape get rid of the roads
that ran through the center of the
campus and the trash pickup and
restaurant pickup build a series of new
buildings at the entry which are new
restaurants a bookstore and ticketing
and then this whole below ground passage
and the above ground passes there's two
routes going parallel to each other that
enter into a new building here that
leads to new exhibition spaces so quite
complicated in a sense of working within
a fairly complex environment original
buildings done by thummim alfred bands
Feld building by Frederick keesler that
houses all the Dead Sea Scrolls this is
a large you Simone Iguchi sculpture
garden outside so a lot of key pieces
within the campus and then our work was
really how you would take this hole
insertion into the campus and remove
those roads and build a set of ground
walkway so the excavations up through
the campus and then super imposition of
a drawing of the old walkway being put
back down water elements bringing light
into the below ground space and it's the
new building be inserted this is this
walkway and then how that gets
transformed into this that's basically
the new passageway which is below ground
and this you you standing here you're
actually almost 20 meters below ground
so you're safe for us 60 feet below
ground how do you make that field day
lit how do you get people that are that
far below ground to feel like they're
connected to the landscape of nature and
the quality is of light so we have these
courtyards outside that bring in light
and there's they're all grown plant
so you have a sense of greenery along
here and then there's a water element
that runs along the whole walkway that
allows sunlight to come through it and
then animate that whole lower lower
space so little sections of that new
buildings and equipment coming up all
the way up into the space and and that
was that entry below ground and then for
the building's themselves above ground
as I said wanting to build buildings out
of entirely out of just not even
insulated glass but just clear laminated
glass the buildings are all glass we
then framed them or house them in these
shading pavilions and we developed two
different configurations one shading
system for the east west of the
buildings obviously where the gets a low
angle of sunrise and low angle of sunset
where you get the most heat coming into
the building 11 elevation for those two
exposures then a different shading
system for the north south which can be
much more open but the principle here is
with these extrusions which I'll show
you these are ceramic extrusions as the
sunlight comes down and then it's design
in such a way that it has a slight curve
inside so the light hits on the outside
and then the light bounces back and then
illuminates the inner surface so the
outer wall basically is taking or
actually sloped a little bit taking the
light and bouncing it back on itself so
when you're in the building the whole
what you would think would be shadow or
shaded is actually all illuminated with
very soft light and then you have this
phenomenon that happens which is
demonstrated here is even though you
don't see what's outside is completely
blocked you don't have a direct vision
you can actually see the shape of trees
and the color of trees and all of that
soar in so it's again it's again a way
of trying to constantly engage people
with landscape and qualities of nature
around you but just invent a way that
first and foremost protects you from the
intensity of the light but still keeps
you involved so these are the North
South elevation which you can obviously
see through that has a sort of an
unusual profile to it as well which does
the same thing
and then there's oftentimes shaded areas
between the glazed areas so there's
shaded cooler walking areas around the
outsides of the buildings and this is
walking under trellis area up into that
below ground passage and you look you're
looking through the passage at the
beginning and it continues off your left
here and you can see people walking on
the old paths up above there so you got
people walkin it to two different
elevations and when you're in that space
you sort of end up with this sort of
quality of light and the light is coming
in because we have this water element
overhead with light coming down that's
the diffused glass wall of the tunnel
with these courtyards that are sort of
intermittent along the walkway so here
it is the glass so this is a little bit
if you think back to that project at
Hearst buildings i showed you before
which is here on the hudson on eighth
avenue that have those cast glass
elements we're running that chilled
water over it when we built that we
hadn't really thought of this but if you
go back in the mechanical room which is
where the pumps are all that you can
actually look right through it and we
said well this is like pretty
spectacular so looking at all this water
coming down but nobody sees it except
the maintenance people so we actually
sort of then designed this whole system
so that you're down below you can look
up you actually the water's running over
the surface the Sun comes through the
water so that whole space is sort of
animated by qualities of lights so these
are the other space you come out of that
below ground passage up into these new
spaces that's sort of the quality of
light on that completely shaded surface
that you can see there and just give you
a little sense of some of these spaces
so I guess just this last slide so just
in summary you know as architects and
designers I think that we do we do a lot
of work with as I said with Corning
Glass Works and
we've done a lot of work with little bit
ax we've done a lot of thermo take
plants that are designed just for peak
production you know in Texas in Arizona
when everything those peak hours they
just are used only for two o'clock to
five o'clock in the afternoon that come
online but I think that this opportunity
that glass currently is sort of offering
with these very very thin glasses there
are ways of introducing much higher
technologies into the glass as a thin
film than there ever would have been on
these thicker types of glasses the same
way we use glass today and we apply
coatings to it like loi coatings or
highly reflective coatings or you know
any type of instrumentation coatings to
it the glass is simply serving as a
substrate but with thin film glasses
today which I said are you know
literally the thickness of the paper you
can actually introduce much higher
technologies to it for instance one of
the things we're working on right now is
relative to healthcare issues is that
you can include silver halide in the
glass composition itself and those types
of chemicals basically kill bacteria and
viruses so you can actually produce a
glass a super thin film glass that would
be bonded to like all surfaces and doors
everything all the all these things
would be made out of glass today and
would prevent sort of the spread of
bacteria and viruses so there's a huge
opportunities for things as simple as
that for these thin film glasses but for
architecture similarly you can introduce
very sophisticated luring systems
shading systems electrochromic systems
other things that you would never been
able to afford to do previously so
there's a big transformation which will
probably take you know another 10 years
actually happen because there's no
industry out there that can actually
deal with these thin glasses so it's so
it's a way it's trying to establish like
what what type of industry is that that
can handle
these new glasses it's totally different
than the current industry and how you
begin to introduce that and how that can
contribute to you no buts or power
opportunities and daylighting
opportunities all these things that
happen on buildings so it's probably
little different than the other talks
you've been hearing but it might be a
might have been of interest anyway